mais d'abord l'évolution génétique du
cornât virus l'émergence des variants et
des prochaines mutation préoccupante
tu seras skov de les chercheurs traque
le virus pas à pas pour mieux le
comprendre et le déjouer
[Musique]
quelque part en 2019 des mutations
génétiques fortuite ont permis à un
nouveau virus
le strass kof xii d'affecter les noms de
se répandre
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
virus passe de l'animal à l'humain et
s'installe mais aujourd'hui pour la
première fois de l'histoire
il est possible de traquer chacun de ses
pas de son évolution
jamais autant de séquences et de
séquences d'une seule souche que
maintenant sous nos yeux le virus mute
et s'adapte à son nouvel environnement
l'humain et aurait pas de procès
d'assises sans précédent comme un sou
payons chaque étape de l'évolution du
strass cov de chaînes à l'habitude c'est
à la fois intéressant et effrayant parce
que c'est voir l'évolution en marche
il est de plus en plus redoutable mais
nous sommes mieux armés que jamais pour
traquer son évolution
[Musique]
voici la rn du tout premier sera skov de
séquencer une succession de 30000 bases
azotées il vient d'un individu ayant
fréquenté le marché de wuhan en chine
fin 2019
c'est notre point de départ on va dire
de haut niveau génétique juillet une
spécialiste de l'évolution des
populations analysé séquence de virus en
provenance du monde entier à mesure
qu'elles sont partagés au tout début
le virus est en pleine expansion il
conquiert l'humain dans chaque nouvelles
cellules qu'il infecte il se réplique
des 1023 créant des copies identiques du
génome original ou presque de temps à
autre une erreur sincère une base à
sauter et remplacée par une autre où
disparaît
parfois c'est sans effet mais parfois la
mutation lui confère de nouvelles
aptitudes qui l'aide à se répliquer où
se transmettre au début de la pandémie
ça peu d'importance le virus se répand
sans réel obstacle
il était connu notre système immunitaire
si le virus était capable d'infecter des
cellules humaines et était capable de se
transmettre d'un autre à l'autre il
fonctionne bien
les mutations qu'il va accumuler de
façon neutre ou aléatoires vont être
suffisante pour assurer sa propagation
ici le virus originale de the wall sa
descendance se diversifie peu à peu au
printemps le virus accumule des
mutations sans incidence clair sur ses
capacités
un rythme régulier environ une mutation
aux deux semaines
c'est assez lent quatre fois plus lent
que pour le virus de la grippe ces
lignes et s'ils dominent en asie
celle-ci se répandent en europe celle ci
aux états unis ça c'est un arbre
phylogénétique et c'est la sphère de
jesse shapiro il est clair que le virus
est capable de se propager
mais ils évoluent pas chez l'humain
depuis longtemps on peut donc prédire
qu'il n'est pas à son optimum évolutive
dans l'humain ils se retrouvent dans les
mains un peu par hasard ce qui signifie
qu'il a de nombreuses façons s'améliorer
enjoy
il existe des centaines de mutation qui
pourrait améliorer sa capacité à se
reproduire et à survivre
[Musique]
c'est ce que redoute les scientifiques
tôt ou tard à force de se multiplier
le virus va gagner une de ces mutations
avantageuses c'est là où la sélection
naturelle entre en jeu est ce qu'il est
capable d'infecter plus de cellules que
son voisin ou moins de cellules et donc
si plus de cellules alors c'est lui qui
va prendre le pas et avoir une majorité
de s'infecter une majorité de cellules
alors plus de chances d'être celui qui
est transmis à la prochaine personne les
mois passent les scientifiques font
l'inventaire des mutations
c'est crucial pour comprendre leur rôle
car la rnc le manuel de construction du
virus chacune de ces portions sert à
fabriquer une des 16 protéines internes
qui font fonctionner virus
celle ci les spicules qui forment sa
couronne caractéristiques et si les
protéines qui composent l'enveloppent du
virus au fil du temps certaines parties
du jeune homme gagne plus souvent des
mutations
c'est alors peut-être un signe que le
virus bénéficient de ces changements
[Musique]
mais avril une mutation se démarque sur
un grand nombre de souches séquence est
un as est devenu un danger à la position
614 le plus inquiétant c'est que cette
mutation affecte le spicules c'est la
partie exposée du virus c'est la clé qui
lui permet de pénétrer les cellules
humaines
c'est aussi la principale cible du
système immunitaire et des vaccins au
début de la pandémie c'était très
difficile de faire la part des choses
est ce que il ya vraiment ici juste un
effet de transmission et de jeu de
transmission entre les humains ou est ce
qu'il ya vraiment où est ce qu'on
pourrait commencer à détecter une
adaptation avec cette mutation le virus
y at il des gagner un nouvel avantage si
oui lequel
partout au monde des chercheurs scrutent
cette mutation comme un dress finzi un
virologue dans son laboratoire au centre
de recherche du chum il a créé des virus
présentant les spicules du sras skov de
certains avec cette nouvelle mutation
quand on a vu les premiers mais rien qui
est arrivé on a modifié la clé d'entrée
pour tenir compte de ces mutations
on met la même quantité particules
virales sur des cellules susceptibles et
après on regarde dans quel contexte on a
plus des cellules infectées
on s'est aperçu assez rapidement qui
était pas mal plus affectueux ce à
devenu un j'ai changé un élément du
spicules juste ici ce qui le rend plus
stable
le virus se transmet mieux en quelques
semaines ce variant des 614 et se
répandent partout sur la planète
et se diversifie au printemps 2020 cette
version améliorée remplace la ligne et
1c strahl aujourd'hui presque éteinte
puis arrive décembre au royaume uni
une nouvelle version du virus se répand
comme une traînée de poudre il est
environ 50% plus transmissible une
nouvelle glacial pour les agences de
santé publique à travers le monde comme
au québec où sandrine moreira coordonne
le séquençage et l'analyse du virus
provenant des québécois infectés donc au
début la première idée 7 est mince ya eu
un problème au niveau du séquençage
il ya des mutations qui sont ajoutés
s'est passé quelque chose puis
finalement en creusant ce qu'ils sont
aperçus c'est que non c'est
qu'effectivement le virus avait acquis
plus de mutations
le plus troublant c'est qu'en plus de la
mutation des 614 g
ce nouveau variant a soudainement
accumulé une vingtaine de mutation dont
huet affectant le spicules sur son arbre
évolutif
ce variant apparaît comme une branche à
part signe d'une évolution accélérée
tout était plutôt homogène donc le virus
il évolue quand même à une vitesse qui
est relativement homogène puis ces
variants là il sortait de l'arbre est en
fait il avait accumulé beaucoup plus de
mutations que les autres virus et qu'on
pourrait s'attendre à 7 mètres même
période de l'année
comment le virus a pu réaliser ce bon
évolutif la principale hypothèse est
qu'il a évolué au sein d'un habitat
idéal une personnes immunosupprimées
chez cette personne là la réponse une
étape assez fort pour contenir le virus
mais pas assez fort pour lui mais
rapidement
cherry a copy cello décortique la
réaction du système immunitaire devant
le strass cov de ce qui provoque le
virus une situation où lui peut quand
même persister un peu plus longtemps
dans l'autre effecto lui demande le
temps de se diviser un peu plus
longtemps d'acquérir quelques mutations
en pull autre possibilité le virus
aurait acquis ses nombreuses mutations
dans d autres animaux c'est une
possibilité car un événement semblable
s'est produit au danemark
quelques mois plus tôt où le virus a
infecté des visons d'élevage de
l'histoire des visons était pour moi une
alerte très important pour la communauté
scientifique et médicale
le virus a gagné des nouvelles mutations
danse et vise en créant des variantes
transmis à au moins 214 personnes
par prévention 17 millions de vison ont
été abattus l'évolution au sein de ces
espèces là elle est inconnue mais elle
pourrait mener à toute une série de
mutations différentes de celles qui
seraient attendus chez l'humain
donc il s'est un peu un terrain de jeu
de choix pour eux ils peuvent muter
essayer des choses et ainsi de suite
le variant britannique a été un réveil
brutal de quel autre ruse le virus est
elle capable
ce qui nous inquiète un petit peu c'est
que si on arrive à voir jump comme ça un
saut comme ça de mutation c'est que
potentiellement dans la population
humaine en ce moment il ya plusieurs
endroits patient ou ce genre de choses
peut se passer
d'autres variantes remplace rapidement
les lignes précédentes en afrique du sud
au brésil en californie aux etats unis
plusieurs compte aussi plusieurs
mutations des sceaux évolutif il ne se
passait pas grand chose dans l'évolution
de strass causes jusqu'en décembre nous
avons vu des mutations s'accumuler mais
à un rythme assez régulier en 17 portées
à ma part des 614 auger rien ne semblait
apporter un avantage de transmission et
tout d'un coup nous voyons surgir au
moins trois lignes et indépendante pour
le virus quelque chose a changé dans son
paysage adaptatif y adapte ce qu'est ce
qui a changé entre autres à l'automne le
nombre de personnes affectées est plus
élevé plus il ya de contacts plus yade
virus puis ya décès et plus on n'essaie
plus on a de chance de trouver une
combinaison qui va marcher qui va être
gagnant pour le virus aussi dans
certains pays le nombre de personnes
naturellement immunisées est de plus en
plus élevés il est possible que nous
arrivions un point de pandémie ce genre
d'adaptation commence à devenir
avantageux parce qu'il ya plus vais
militer dans la population et nous
protège
les variants préoccupant se multiplient
mais plusieurs partage des mutations
commune par exemple une mutation sur le
spicules la n 501 y
elle permet au virus de mieux se lie aux
récepteurs des cellules humaines ce qui
le rend plus transmissible la 1e 484
qu'à lui permet d'échapper à certains
anticorps et auraient permis d'y
réinfection et d'autres c'est la même
mutation s'est produite indépendamment
plusieurs fois la structure forte de
sélection naturelle les plus probable
que cela se produise plusieurs fois et
dépendamment à moins que cette mutation
procure vraiment un avantage sélectif
al'avantage de transmission
à tâtons le virus s'adapte à l'humain il
est de plus en plus habiles à déjouer
ses défenses il explore son paysage
mutationnelles de façon un peu aléatoire
mais vu de l'extérieur quand on regarde
et mettez les mutations qui reste on
dirait vraiment une stratégie de guerre
c'est à dire qu on a l'impression qu'il
y est extrêmement efficace à trouver les
bonnes imitations le virus sras skov 2
connaît un boom évolutif mais jusqu'à
quand sommes nous arrivés un plateau ou
juste au début d'un pont qui se
poursuivra tellement facteurs en jeu
c'est très difficile à prévoir
[Musique]
la troisième vague et commencer le varia
redevenez graduellement de mineurs
on connaît à présent le variant
britannique celui du brésil d'afrique du
sud du nigeria de californie aux etats
unis
il remplace les nuits précédentes cause
de nouvelle vague d'hospitalisation mais
ce n'est pas fini
le virus continue d'évoluer des dizaines
d'autres variant suspects sont sur le
radar des scientifiques
ils essayent donc ils ajoutent des
mutations et ya la possibilité qu avec
des mutations supplémentaires mais il
change encore son comportement et might
be - à cuincy nouveaux variants pourrait
devenir plus transmissible
il pourrait aussi devenir plus pathogène
ce qui signifie qu'il pourrait causer
des symptômes plus graves est très
important il pourrait devenir résistant
aux anticorps stimulée par les vaccins
parmi toutes les nouvelles lignes
émergentes
comment repérer celles qui doivent nous
inquiéter et les stopper une vaste
chasse est en cours
[Musique]
au royaume uni le variant britannique
est à présent responsable de la quasi
totalité des nouveaux cas au canada dans
plusieurs provinces
il est devenu la ligne est dominante la
maladie va se transmettre beaucoup plus
facilement dans la population plus de
cas plus d'hospitalisations plus de
décès donc c'est ça qu'on veut éviter la
vigie génétique de la queue vide au
québec se trouve au laboratoire national
de santé publique
d'ici on coordonne l'analyse génétique
des échantillons des québécois infecté
le criblage c'est un test parfait quand
c'est quoi chercher sur le génome
au québec on surveille 3 mutation
spécifique
la n 501 y l'a eu 4 184 cas la délétion
69-66 une approche rapide pour repérer
les principaux variant prix du pain
mais en tout temps de nouvelles
mutations se produisent partout ailleurs
sur le génome
il faut donc aussi surveiller ses autres
mutations afin d'intercepter l'émergence
de nouveaux variants en sol québécois
et ça ce n'est pas 6 heures pour cela il
ya un aspect qu a bâti une brigade de
chercheurs dont fait partie julie us le
problème c'est que ya énormément de
mutation qui serait bien de savoir sur
lesquels se concentraient il ya vraiment
une grande probabilité de se concentrer
sur la mauvaise en priorité on surveille
les éclosions de grande ampleur un signe
possible de présence d'une nouvelle
version du virus
ça c'est peut-être un signe s'il en fût
s'il est plus présent dans des éclosions
qu' il va être plus transmissible parce
qu'un cas va générer plus de cas alors
pas le choix conséquence tout le génome
à la recherche des nouvelles mutations
autres suspects les versions du virus
qui semble échapper au système
immunitaire au vaccin des virus
provenant de patients victimes d'une
seconde infection et ceux infectés après
vaccination
ce qu'on va traquer c'est les virus qui
vont trouver finalement la bonne
combinaison pour échapper à l'efficacité
vaccinale déjà plusieurs nouveaux
variants sont sous observation et toute
une stratégie déployée pour les analyser
celle ci commence chez guy boivin un
spécialiste des maladies infectieuses
émergentes tout ligne est suspecte est
envoyé à son laboratoire haute sécurité
ici son équipe comparé le comportement
des nouvelles versions du virus avec
celui des versions originales sur des
cellules humaines et sur des animaux
parce que le taux de transmission le
varia est supérieur ou non toute
transmission du virus l'original c'est
ce qu'on appelle mesurer l'impact
fonctionnel et quand on combine soit aux
analyses épidémiologiques
mais on peut dire avec plus de sur ce
que oui on a affaire à un nouveau
variant est ce de varia lauriers
préoccupant ou non dès qu'une ligne et
de virus se démarque adresse fini
intervient lui analyse comment ces
nouvelles mutations modifie la forme de
spicules et analysent tout changement de
la réponse immunitaire et nous
souhaitons vous introduit les mutations
très rapidement et on regarde à ce que
ça affecte l'affinité pour les
récepteurs
est-ce que ça augmente la fictive dans
l'effectivité des particules virales
est-ce que sa charge la forme de la clé
des façons de telles que les anticorps
qui dégénéraient par l'infection ou par
la vaccination s'est répétée de moins
efficace
de son côté pour comprendre le rôle de
chacune des nouvelles mutations repéré
le virologiste genzyme construit de
véritables virus sras skov de complet
sur mesure
départ c'est le nouveau varia c'est un
seul virus mais il porte plusieurs
mutations disons d'ici mutation pour
comprendre quelles mutations font quoi
nous allons fabriquer 10 virus chacun ne
porte qu'une seule de ces mutations
en étudiant ces dix virus différents
nous serons quelles mutations donne
quelques propriétés haut var ya par
exemple une augmentation de la
transmission ou de sa pathogénicité avec
cette stratégie
lyès pq pourrait détecter en moins de
deux semaines la propagation d'un
variant émergents au québec
c'est certain que le virus aura toujours
une petite longueur d'avancé parce que
lui muté nous on est derrière à regarder
comment il a muté mais je suis confiante
par rapport à la stratégie qu est mise
en place
il demeure cependant la crainte numéro 1
qu'à force de muter le virus échappe au
vaccin
mais les études des dernières semaines
dont celle d'andré swing s'y attarde
excellente nouvelle chantre ici on a
testé les vaccins des fighters high tech
etc en regard des types d'anticorps qui
sont générés c'est un décor sont
capables de reconnaître tous les
différends va rien que n'a testé des
résultats rassurants
considérant que les premiers essais de
vaccins contre certains variants avait
inquiété il suggérait une diminution de
leur efficacité
en fait il avait observé une diminution
de la capacité des anticorps générés par
les vaccins à neutraliser le virus à
l'empêcher d'infecter les cellules
humaines
or en étudiant des sujets montréalais
andré screens y observe que la
protection conférée par les vaccins est
aussi attribuable à un second phénomène
jusqu'ici ignoré les anticorps ont aussi
la capacité d'appeler à l'aide d'autres
cellules du système immunitaire capable
de combattre le virus
une fonction qui ne semblent pas
affectés par les variants donc qu'à
chaque fois on dit les variants il
s'échappe durée peau de la réponse
immunitaire
attention il échappe d'une petite partie
de la réponse immunitaire qui est la
réponse de neutralisation mais
heureusement qui ad'autres mécanisée que
les anticorps font d'autres choses que
notre avis c est chez les patients
vaccinés qui avait été préalablement
infectés par l'aco vide
la réponse est spectaculaire une réponse
observés en laboratoire ou un fnb
exposent leurs anticorps ovarian et même
à un autre virus celui du strass qui
avait sévi en 2003 on donne une danse
des vaccins trois semaines plus tard
cédant tapis ils reconnaissent tous les
barrières et connaissent le strass
pour anne reste fine si c'est une preuve
de la grande capacité des vaccins et du
système immunitaire à reconnaître son
ami malgré de multiples mutations
autre élément rassurant avec la
vaccination
la population du virus devrait
s'effondrer comme ces occasions de muter
et le nombre de variants aussi 13
vaccins sont en ce moment à prouver près
d'une centaine à l'essai avec des
approches et les cibles distingue le
virus est de plus en plus restreints
dans ses mutations
il peut pas le faire aussi bien qu il
veut il doit compenser il peut pas faire
n'importe quel changement
l'effet d'essayer d'échapper à une
réponse se peut vous rendre potable plus
vulnérables à d'autres réponses où ça
peut faire en sorte que pour pour
s'échapper décès d'une réponse
immunitaire notamment mais que vous
perdiez la capacité à mieux vous
transmettre ou infectés reste que selon
une majorité d'experts les chances
d'éradiquer le virus sont minces parce
que on sait pas à quelle vitesse on va
être capable déployer des vaccins un peu
partout dans le monde
ce qu'on va être capable d
nécessairement de vacciner tout le monde
il ya toujours une inconnue est ce que
si les virus très bien vers un réservoir
animal et après ils sortent chez l'homme
et c est ce qu il faudra un rennais avec
des vaccins
légèrement modifié pour qu'il connaisse
pour qu'il pût soient capables de
reconnaître des clés qui serait
légèrement modifié
donc il est possible qu on aura besoin à
un intervalle je ne sais pas c'est serra
lequel probablement une année de
redonner une nouvelle un nouveau vaccin
je pense qu'on va apprendre à vivre avec
ce virus là le sera ce kof 2 entrera
alors au répertoire des virus qui
cohabite avec nous comme ceux de la
grippe ou des coronavirus qui causent
les roms comme d'autres virus humain
l'ont fait selon des chercheurs
les variants convergeront vers un petit
nombre de lignes et nani à tout
compétiteur supérieur l'emportera sur
les autres comme l'a fait le va-et-vient
britannique ovarien remplace un autre
car il n'ya en fait qu'une espèce pacte
c'est difficile d'imaginer qu'il
pourrait y avoir le métier stable de 2
ou 3 digne et turcs lui sanguinet jazz
c'est fascinant de voir ce processus est
positif en temps réel on est en train de
voir ça se produire de mesurer toutes
ces billets qui ultima vont disparaître
combien de temps le vaccin nous
protégera t-il le virus échappera-t-il
au vaccin
deviendra-t-il moins mortelles des
questions en ce moment sans réponse qui
définiront notre cohabitation future
avec le virus
[Musique]